crazy founder story
yours or otherwise or crazy capital
allocated story one of the things that
you've sort of talked about is you know
it's okay if um founders are getting
sort of one to five million because
nobody wants like a founder who's so
preoccupied with their bills and their
you know they're maintaining their lives
that they can't work for you like that's
or not work for you but work with you
like that's not
what you want but you want them to go
along for sure for sure and so what but
what i'm also starting to see as i'm
starting to see and you kind of touched
on this is that in these later stages
there are
um
founders who are getting to take
20 50
off the table
and
at that point it makes me feel very
uncomfortable because i'm like you know
if you make 20 to 50 million dollars
that is more that is quite a
likely
yeah it's a life-changing amount of
money for somebody who most likely three
years ago had nothing and so that's all
you're talking about to be clear here
we're not talking about a 10 to 20 year
old company no no we're talking about a
sub five year old company
which
is dispropor they're taking more money
off the table and the company has
revenue in that course most likely yes
in that instance yes and it's and it's
and these are being built into it's not
even that anybody else has a say it's
it's being built into the contract as
such that you know if taking over this
term sheet comes with the
sort of um
comes with the claws that you actually
have to sell up that you actually have
to sell us your shares because we're not
getting enough allocation via the round
we'll just buy shares off the ceo we'll
pay whatever the market price is cash
them out and in some instances i've seen
people get close to 50 million dollars
via these sort of mechanisms and to me
that feels very very frothy top
uncomfortable because you're kind of
rewarding somebody for a job not yet
done you're kind of saying hey michael
jordan you took us to the second round
of the playoffs but yeah here's your
ring yeah here's your ring and so it's
like yeah i'm not exactly yeah they're
still fourth place
yeah fourth place eighth best
fourth best team like yeah you're not
quite there yeah and i that is i i think
that's an eloquent way to describe it
which is
we're starting to give people right i
don't mind people getting a little extra
credit
but if we're giving people
you know their championship and their
oscar
before they've even you know edited the
film exactly you're like wow great
screenplay those you know the trailer
looks awesome but like script like what
a script yes
and here's your oscar it's like uh i
kind of want to see
the film first
i think that this kind of idea where
we're rewarding people for
almost finished work is something that's
going to come back and bite us in the
ass because in essence we're valuing
80 of the job like we're saying you know
you deserve to be rewarded for
almost getting to where you told us that
you would go and because you're so close
and we can see where you we can see the
kind of a to b of you getting to that
actual end place we'll just call it here
and say that you did your job you know i
think kryptos
got this going on in a crazy way listen
i don't want to uh give anybody a hard
time about their investments but yeah
you know all my friends are in solana
and i was like wow congratulations this
is like the greatest return in the
history of venture capital or something
and i had you know um
sam from slow on and i was like well
that's great you know you returned 2
billion from a 500k investment obviously
it's not liquid obviously there's not
enough buyers to buy out 49 billion
dollars worth of solana right but i'm
like they have eight
developers
and because at the salon i found iran i
was like you have eight developers you
have 45
7 billion dollars it's like it's six
billion dollars per developer
you know we were talking how crazy it
was when facebook was doing aqua hires
at 6 million right right right 6 billion
and that to me is super dangerous
because how does the company grow from
here how does an investor put money in
and expect any kind of return i don't
know if you saw fred wilson's blog post
but he wrote this blog post of like
uh if you're pre-product
pre-product forget about pre-product
market fit pre-product
you haven't built the product and it's
at 100 million how does a fund
ever
returned 20 percent irr it's just not he
made a model he said maybe i don't
understand it maybe there's going to be
100 or 200 trillion dollar companies but
yeah this doesn't add up yeah basically
you're expecting that you know when you
know 10 years ago when all of us were so
happy that you know we had a unicorn in
our portfolio now it's like unless you
have a deck of corn because you invested
so late it doesn't like if you're
investing at 100 million seed you need a
deca corn for it even to make sense
what's the worst behaviors or just
sticks with your story about this moment
in time on the vc side or on the
founder's side
yeah i think i think one thing that is
kind of leaving a bad taste in my mouth
is like you know we always as an
industry have spent a lot of money on
like you know parties and events and off
sites and things but it seems to have
reached like an inflection point now
where it's like people are just not even
being at all specific or seemingly
having any sort of
like corporate strategy as to why
they're doing these things it just seems
kind of like for the sake of you know
having our names in people's mouths
we're gonna spend a million dollars on
an art basel activation
and when you ask like okay well how does
that translate into customers and how
does that you know how does that sort of
what's the feedback loop between your
enterprise sas uh product and this soho
beach house party that you just threw
it's really really hard to get from a to
b and i think that like again we're in
one of those fly wheels where it's like
oh well
you know x company that just raised 10
billion just did this massive activation
and xy company that just did this and so
it's like again crazy yeah
the potential for positive change with
ai is huge but seeing that value is hard
ai driven growth is about organizational
transformation not just technology and
many businesses struggle with bringing
ai initiatives to fruition that's where
data iq comes in
data iq is the platform for everyday ai
systemizing the use of data for
exceptional business results at its core
data iq allows companies to leverage one
central solution to design deploy and
manage ai and analytics applications and
it's accessible for everyone whether
technical or if you're on the business
side dataiku also facilitates using
pre-built components and automation
wherever possible to streamline work
processes as well as consistent
management and governance across teams
and projects to create transparent
repeatable and scalable ai and analytics
programs visit data iq to learn more
that's
dataiku.com to learn more